Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
It's June, isn't it.
Know what that means?
I do.
Giant balloons.
Although this ones all skanky.
That is about a year old I think.
Been in the shed since last June.
We've only got enough for
just one video this June.
We're not gonna do a full month.
But I was recently watching
the original giant balloon video
which has over 170 million views
at the time of recording.
And there was a GoPro looking down
and I thought, landing on a balloon
and seeing it from above
would look very cool.
Well, you're right,
but now it meas that your
gonna have to film the slow mo
and I'm gonna be the one jumping.
I've had enough of jumping
from heights recently.
Yeah?
Just finished breaking my wrist.
Jumping onto some wood.
Just got done with that?
Yeah.
I'm finished with that.
So you'll be up the ladder.
Yep.
Hopefully only breaking the
balloon, not your wrist.
And I'll be on the roof,
hopefully not breaking
the camera or my legs.
That's the plan.
That's a tall order, this one.
I really hope I don't break anything.
Yeah, me too.
Here we are again.
I'm actually kind of looking forward to
being splashed to this,
it's really warm.
It's bloody hot, innit?
Yeah.
So this is our standard procedure,
red six-footer.
I didn't think that in 2010
we'd be doing these in 2018.
Neither did I.
You think you would've been
doing something different with your life?
Yes, actually.
Hopefully this cushions you enough
to not hit the ground beneath.
Yeah.
Hopefully.
You want me to swan dive?
I feel like if you swan dive,
that's spreading your weight more evenly.
Than what?
Than like, hitting your legs on it.
Yeah, but your legs are
supposed to go first.
You don't ever let like...
Not on to something softer.
You don't go to gymnastics and go,
"Mate, you land chin first," and then...
"And finish the vault with
a swan dive onto the floor."
But think about it,
if you're landing on
something soft and uneven,
don't really wanna land on your ankles,
I would say.
So we've sort of learnt that,
when you fill one of these,
the weight of the water sort of crushes
a lot of the slack underneath,
leaving the top to become very tight.
So we thought it was a good
idea to massage the balloon.
And you can actually feel and hear it,
like, creaking when you do it.
You can hear that slightly.
Yes, you're just adding
some of it's slack.
You're just adding some slack
to the the top rather
than the bottom by...
It's like weird 'cause
the side move around like
Yeah.
Every time I do it.
I'm nervous, this is my nervous face.
Looks pretty nervous.
When you're up there,
'cause I'm six foot tall,
if I'm on an eight foot ladder,
it makes it really high.
I don't think this is a six foot balloon.
It's certainly looks like
it's filling up like at the neck,
which means its almost full to capacity.
It looks extra bloated,
but it's not very .
I swear the one I jumped on spread wider.
Maybe it's 'cause its been
in the shed since June.
Maybe we've gotta get better balloons.
Yeah.
What?
Let's give it a shove.
Out we go.
You'll pass it to me, yeah.
Yeah.
Not a good start.
Now if you fall, grab on to the gutter.
It'll definitely break,
which should slow you down just enough.
Great.
'Scuse me.
Okay, I'm good.
I'll head back down.
What did you do today?
Oh, you know.
Just climbed out on my roof
and dangled a high-speed cinema camera
while some other bloke
jumped on a balloon.
You all right?
Yeah.
You ready to take now, should I go?
All right.
How was that?
Oh, I got winded.
You all right?
Actually, yeah.
I went for it, winded
myself when I landed.
'Cause it was kind of like,
belly flopping but not.
'Cause you belly flop and you just go...
And then it burst.
It felt like I landed, went...
So it was kind of like landing
on a fat cushion of water.
Oh, the ripples.
Wow.
The half of that balloon's burst
by the time of the other
half even realizes it.
It's like it forgets.
And then I think,
the pressure that you forced
into the side that hasn't burst
then splits right down the middle.
Oh.
Look at your face, Daniel.
I was winded by that.
I like the spread of the water.
It's perfectly even,
you haven't got a shot of that before
where it's completely from above.
You can totally see the spread there.
There's you moving.
Here's me pressing the trigger
and trying not to fall off the roof.
So a lot of the time
whenever we just have one Phantom going,
I like to get it a couple of times
from multiple focal lengths.
I like to get the wide first, you know.
Make sure we've got it.
Then go in for a nice close up.
And if I botched the focus,
you know, it's not a big deal
because we've already got the wide.
I like it.
So that means we have to do it again?
Yep!
I'm actually okay with it.
Because it is really hot out here,
and I am nice and refreshed.
You're probably sweating
up there on the roof.
I'll tell you what.
Having a miserable time.
It's very hot on the knees.
I was like straddling it.
My knees were burning up there.
I should've got some sort of
handheld accessories for this.
Oh, oh gosh.
You all right?
You okay?
Just about.
That one wasn't as good as the one.
It like burst as I hit it,
so I just pretty much
hit the floor that time.
Oh man.
You slid quite a long way.
Yeah I did, I...
I was very surprised at this one,
'cause I was filming like this.
But you slid so far.
So I actually had to track you
because it was a tighter shot.
That's a hell of a move.
Being on the roof, being
like, improvising, track that.
Top of your head.
Lovely bald spot going on there.
Friar tuck action.
Almost identical way of falling as well.
Yeah, I think you've
definitely found your way.
And then it split.
It split from around the edge
and came up to me.
That's a weird one, innit.
I don't think we've seen that before.
You see on this one, I pretty
much just hit the floor
and the balloon sort of got in the way.
On the first one, it felt
like almost like cushioned me
and then let me go, it
was much more comfortable.
This one was just sort of like, bang.
If I speed this one up,
you can see how far you slid.
Good tracking job there!
Oh, cheers, thanks.
Solid.
As with any sudden release of water,
you cause like a flood effect,
a sudden damaging effect.
We've managed to wash away
all the topsoil from around the tree.
Just in one hit.
Completely just gone.
You know, it's Texas, so the
plants need watering anyway.
Well to make up for this,
I've not run the sprinklers
for the last 18 months,
so the grass should enjoy that.
Do you mean the sprinklers you bought
specifically to just do a prank on me
and then never used?
Oh .
That, yes, that's right.
Oh yeah, okay.
Well, the sprinklers were already there.
The controller I specifically bought.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I love that you're like,
"Oh, I've got an automated
house with sprinklers,
"never use them though."
There's no point.
Waste of water.
That's actually true.
Coming from the two blokes
who just did that.
That wasn't a waste though.
That was, that,
because we, A, watered plants.
B, it was fun.
So, while we were just making this video,
we received delivery of this,
which, because this comes out in June,
the audience has already
seen in a lot of videos
we're about to make.
But for us, we just got it.
So we're gonna use it.
It will do twelve and a half thousand
frames a second in HD.
So, I don't think I've ever seen
a giant balloon pop so slow.
No, I definitely haven't.
Are you gonna do this one on the roof, or?
No.
No, not gonna take this one on the roof.
Well, I just don't think
it's gonna add a lot from the roof.
I wanna see it pop around the sides.
Three, two, one, jump!
I bounced off it first!
It fully cushioned me
and then I landed again.
Oh, I got like a right
slap on my side there.
I'm not sure how well I got that.
You fell really fast.
Yeah, we've only got blue left
which matches the blue tarp
which is kind of inconvenient, actually.
That should suffice.
Looks like the balloons like an extension
of the tarp.
The tarp.
Three, two, one, jump!
Jesus!
You just went straight through the floor!
Got absolute slapping.
God!
The first time it did that,
I just like bounced slightly
and then landed and it broke.
This time I went straight through it.
Just went.
Yeah.
That looked quite refreshing.
Oh, really was.
Yeah.
I'm nice a refreshed now,
you must be nice and hot.
I am hot, it was very hot up on the roof.
And I didn't break anything!
Very happy with that.
I'm also happy I didn't
slip through the roof
and fall into the house.
Yeah.
Although, holding a Phantom,
that would've been an
interesting piece of footage.
You should've done this,
if you landed, you'd just gone,
"Push the button!"
Trigger it.
Triggered it, yeah.
Hopefully you enjoyed that
lovely giant balloon video.
Feel free to follow us on
the various social medias,
it's all in the description.
Instagram.
Yeah.
We're more Instagram boys these days.
Not that we post any more than on Twitter.
By that, we mean we post
once every like, month.
We've gotta get better.
I know, we're not very good at this.
We've gotta get better at social media,
better at YouTube.
We're just terrible!
Go follow us anyway, right.
We also have a second channel.
And it's a pretty sweet
prank that I did to Dan
with the diamond play button.
Oh, that sucked.
I had you.
All right, we'll see
you in the next video.